ein toilettenhäuschen und ein schloss
tor
das alles hat günter bei nacht gebaut
es ist das schloss mansfeld im deutschen
bundesland sachsen anhalt im maßstab 1
zu 25
eineinhalb jahre betrug die bauzeit kann
jedoch mehr als 80 modelle von in
deutschland real existierenden burgen
und schlössern hat er mittlerweile
87-jährige hobbybastler gebaut
allein in seiner heimatstadt gerbstedt
in sachsen anhalt stehen mehr als 40
[Musik]
sein größtes werk ist das schloss
mansfeld es hat einen umfang von 38
metern und ist sogar begehbar
[Musik]
das bauwerk thront auf einer fläche von
120 quadratmetern das echte schloss
steht auf der burg mansfeld im südharz
im elften jahrhundert erbaut war sie
einst die größte festung in
mitteldeutschland das los wer team ist
auch eine arbeit von günter weihnachts
sein baumaterial zement und bauschutt
die hab ich geschlafen und der wieder
zusammengefügt aber jeder eckstein
musste mit der zange bearbeitet werden
keine technik alles per hand so formte
er tausenden in die ziegelsteine günther
barth hat einst maurer gelernt als
modell vorlage nimmt er lediglich kleine
sammelbilder die gab es in den 1930 er
und 40er jahren beim kauf von zigaretten
dazu
[Musik]
die vorgabe gegen ein haus gebaut als
fantasie burg um war ich mich dran ihn
gefreut habe ich weiß auch nicht dass
ich dazu entwickelt hat 1949 hat gunter
weinerth mit dem bogen bauen begonnen
und konnte nicht mehr aufhören
irgendwann wurden es so viele dass im
eigenen garten kein platz mehr war da
half die stadt und bot ihm flächen zum
aufstellen an geld hat er für keine
seiner wogen bekommen
ich mache hier vor der bevölkerung und
worte kinder vor allen dingen und die
hören sich vor hinunter das ergebnis ist
mein lohn günther bei nacht ist ein
phänomen
denn er hat nicht nur bogen sondern auch
lokomotiven gebaut und dabei an jedes
noch so kleine detail gedacht
die modelle stehen auf dem ehemaligen
güterbahnhofsgelände darunter eine der
weltweit größten lokomotiven genannt big
boi und deutschlands erste dampflok die
adler aus dem jahr 1835
ich hatte aber kollegen von sangerhausen
da hat mich mit bildmaterial versorgt
und da hat mich einer lokomotive ich
habe mehrere andere und sind über 40 42
lokomotiven hin ihr euch standen die
modelle sind zu einer attraktion in
gerbstedt geworden
ein burgenwanderweg verbindet alle
miniatur schlösser miteinander auf sein
gesamtwerk ist günter beinert stolz
ich stehe davor jetzt brauche wie hast
du es durch immer wie hast du es hier
machen burgen schlösser und lokomotiven
aus bauschutt und beton dieses
freilichtmuseum ist wohl einzigartig in
der welt
[Musik]